ringrazio di aver solo video sono fa
vigente
oggi siamo su di sé beauty the table mi
chiamo già formati bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo su di olivo un weekend ho fatto ha
deciso di farlo ma come esperimento cioè
nel senso lo faccio e ditemi se volete
che lo continui perché non ero indeciso
se farlo noi diciamo quindi farò sto
primo episodio poi non so se non
continuo fatemelo sapere voi ragazzi
alla fine dell'episodio lasciatemi un
commento qua sotto con scritto no non
continuarlo pure continuano ti ammazzo
la famiglia cioè non roba del genere
ragazzi perfette ragazzi ci siamo
d'altro non è a me ne frega un cazzo
già perché c'è una sedia a rotelle
chiesto figo troppe cose ha camminato
livello difficoltà si non si è mossa con
la merda facciamo sopravvivenza che noi
siamo pro ok la partenza è stata e già è
già stata fantastica ma ho fatto due
secondi di menu e già sono successe cose
strane comunque va bene i nemici in data
non quando sentono romani forti anch'io
quando vado a prendere la roba nel frigo
la notte mia madre si caccia piace
detective so che stavate smontando ma ci
toccherà fare una deviazione sembra
grave una rivolta
forse il fantasma di quel dottore
impazzito che ha fatto a pezzi i suoi
pazienti
non esattamente alcuni pazienti sono
scomparsi un grosso scandalo
comunque fa venire i brividi non
centrale qui castellanos dalla 184 qual
è la situazione basso
qualcuno mi va bene
un cazzo successo regala cristo a casa e
ha chiamato la mamma che è successo
io vorrei capire chi è che chiama al
telefono è e banda interferenze
bellissimo l'altro protagonista un
singolo oh che bel prossima perché ci
fanno andare in posti così fantasy
capitolo una chiamata d'emergenza si tra
l'altro era una chiamata splendida a
cassone un filmato giuro che pensavo
fosse un video fantastico devo entrare
qua dentro tra l'altro mi è imposto
dovevo entrare qua dentro sicuramente
perfetto che si sangue ha pensato
qualcuno avesse scoraggiato quindi
l'allerta brega
rega è la madonna ci siamo partiti in
camera ragazze dell'ospedale ancora
meglio
non sapevo che cosa succede nodi si
guarda di sicuro non stanno guardando i
teletubbies
poi non so che cosa succede ciao come
stai
ma che bella festa doveva essere mi
chiamo sbocciato tutti
ma chi è carini che stanno alla vela
amore trionfa sempre mi piace troppo
la partenza di stagione tu mi fai schifo
bell'inizio è proprio un inizio al silva
buongiorno senza cerca una camera che è
successo cena c'è un tizio f salve cosa
è successo
abbiamo fatto un party è arrivato david
guetta telecamere di sorveglianza ci
diranno di più
ecco fantastico tratto lui lui mi sembra
quello che non abbia avuto della festa
tra tutti quanti e quello che sta messo
meglio le telecamere di sorveglianza
cosa di vedere chi a quello ragazze la
gente che spara e scappa a caso è
normale
altair che cazzo fai qua la ragazza si
iscriverà buongiorno
cosa c'è il no seriamente seriamente da
quando alta ieri è diventato uno zombie
have e potete trasportarsi da quando mi
applicato le forbici nell'occhio
bastardo di me dopo buongiorno amico mi
ha ascoltata e mi dai una mano già
perché sono dove sono due sono freschi
ragazzi ascoltatemi seguì sfociate la
sera bevete tutto il cazzo che vole non
è che potete amico mio tu stai messo
male ma vale forte c'è un tizio dietro
comunque a ma che bel castello marconi
ma che brutto se la mia vita era
regolare un poliziotto che stava
pattugliare poi dal tailleur sono stato
sconfitto e mi ha legato con i piedi al
soffitto un coltello sto tizio raga ma
chi cazzo è quello premi barra
spaziatrice ripetutamente basta così
ragazzi sta dando la caccia perché
funziona a caso lega da adesso in avanti
premette barra spaziatrice in qualsiasi
situazione funziona a che ho fatto
vabbè non facciamo commenti su st parte
perché non sa stand fellow semmai
macelleria per caso un etto di
prosciutto grazie soprattutto a chiesta
gente salve e amore a prima vista
[Musica]
siete fantastici però buongiorno già per
farmi scoprire dopo un secondo di gioco
salve ma quanto è bello le amava sta
andando a prendere prosciutto ragazzi
sta andando del retrobottega varie
spacciatrice raccogli che cazzo raccolgo
le budella ha le chiavi sono le chiavi e
crudo che saranno le stesse l'aver crudo
c'è tanta macelleria buongiorno porca
[ __ ] che dona ma cosa me ne faccio gli
schiavi di merda cosa non ci sono poche
una porta poi dietro e va bene sapevo io
in questo cammino via ovviamente cammi
bravo zio sia grazia che ne sapevo che
c'era una porta voglia non avevo vista
sia bravo simedia voci 45 minuti per
aprire una porta bravissimo non sapete
come ci sono arrivato qua 10 ci sarà un
modo ma pochi perché c'è alta ieri sta
bene non ho capito un cazzo anche al 5
minuti di gioco però non capito niente
non corre cammina pur tranquillo siamo a
gardaland fi tranquillo
chi è che corre no no no no no no no no
no no no
ragazzi e ragazze merda merda lo dico
anch'io adesso occorre sembrava sta che
prima non corre c'è ma cazzo
ok come non detto ma è mai voltarsi ste
cose
la presa no non ci credo sono morto
dovrei farmi trovare pronto a morire mai
scemi ha separato la luiss sono salvate
manco per il cazzo come non detto
ragazzino è certo ma ci mancherebbe
raga io avevo solo chiesto un prosciutto
cosa sto faticosa ha fatto sì sì che
culo ragazzi le sto andando ragazzi ma
quello è stato un deficiente mi ha
salvato la vita ma chi è che mettere le
cose che va beh la samp è bello il tuffo
in piscina e stato bello mi ricordo di
avere di essere andato in una piscina
una volta era più o meno uguale
forse un po più puliti c'era il filtro
qua forse non c'è che si è la madre
possiamo usarlo come ci avete un remo
posso remare sopra di lui barra
spaziatrice sau che fate mi dice che
schifo dello schifo pro ma manco in
outlast ho visto cose così fatemi capire
ragazzi ma perché è il gioco del jazz a
zoppica ma se gatto una gamba che vorrei
vedere ma dove che sono al mandato in un
ospedale in una fa chi è quello tenta
allora se crescita si ascolta non mi
frega tanto la l'uscita ma c'è un tizio
quindi se si muove madonna gli schiaffi
fermi nati un regalo non mi ha toccato a
noi tocca perfetto qua c'è una maschera
più su vado meglio è perché secondo me
mi hanno portato al centro della terra
dato prima che salga una scala amici
vogliono 80 anni qui in italia avevo
bello bravo fantastico ce l'abbiamo
fatta o layout l'astico fronte ragazzi e
un parco giochi veramente cazzo di rumo
rendersi meglio nasco
veloce veloce succedere che hanno
sentito dei rumori pronti mamma setubal
l'ho mangiata la pasta crediti ma se noi
non è mamma e il tizio con la motosega
di prima se fai il bravo ti compro anche
il salame non ti compro un cazzo ragazza
sta segando tutto che cazzo si diverte a
sfondare i muri vabbè ognuno ha i suoi
hobby e cioè io non critico niente ci
mancherebbe è uscito posso andare sì
perfetto ascolta pino e smettila di fare
il grassone perché la donna bruttissimo
ma visto nella vita non ha visto
grandissimo del mondo armani contro
fuori non mi deve vedere bravo
l'osservazione più fantastica della
storia credete se uscite uscite uscite
uscito cito è uscito lo marito non ha
visto se se se
ok ok dove sto dove sto andando ragazzo
che sto andando raccoglie raccolti
bottiglia perché c'è una bottiglia io nè
silvio nè la festa ragazze con i residui
della festa ragazzi fermi tutti dai time
out time out che come posso fare
amicizia questo tizio se non
lanciandogli una bottiglia in faccia a
meno non mi ha visto
diciamo di si visto fantastico grazie a
dio
[Musica]
grandissima donna nanco dei bond aprista
porta per l'amor di dio veloce
bravissimo gesù gesù bella esperienza da
er noah le sedie a rotelle no però mi
sembra di giocare veramente ad auto us
in terza persona è fantastico
fantastico il cast il cazzo proprio
non è male ma questo qua non c'ha le
gambe tranciate grasso c'è ma perché
sono morto certo ma io ci arriva
all'ascensore mito
non va preso
nel caso non avessi capito tu ca nun
grandi smadonnato ho fatto questo meno
male che lui è più monco di me perché
non ha raggiunto non c'è più una gamba
io mamma parte gli spaventi che poi
prendere i giochi così è bellissimo
soprattutto tizio attende l'ascensore è
stato re grazie successo ragazzi sono
determinate ad esso corpo chi è che ma
nache che sbatte le porte così sento
nate all'inizio perfetto vorrei uscire
se non vi dispiace ma qualcosa mi dice
che ha chiuso la porta proprio sono
convinto di sta cosa crea invece no è
aperto sono salvo davvero seriamente che
cazzo succede
cos'è
no ma serio no non ci posso credere
ragazzi veramente io credevo di essermi
salvato il culo quando mi sa che era
meglio dentro succedendo
cos'è che cazzo se no non ho capito ma
certo
mentre va la macchina ingiustamente è la
madonna donne che non ho capito perché
manco 2012 pensa città che si muove ma
certo
ma tranquilli proprio scena romanzo i
giorni capite è crollato tutto questo
succede quando non riordino la mia
stanza e mia mamma si incazza e chi meno
allo stesso risultato non ci sente
nessuno
saranno tutti i morti ma va cosa te lo
fa pensare ancora no
[Applauso]
cazzo
il mio rapporto ma che lei
guarda se fate qualcosa siamo messi
meglio perché tanto peggio di così non
può andare
che bello l'autista se zombie ficato e
siamo caduti da un dirupo meraviglioso
capitolo 1 superato capitolo successivo
allo stupendo comunque cioè io non ho
parole non ha mai sul gioco partire così
bene sono insomma sul letto dove cazzo
storica chiesto tizio cosa perché siamo
su un letto d'ospedale perché sono
caduto da me da 450 metri l'altezza che
adesso ho capito adesso mi è più chiaro
perfetto ci sono ancora vivono si sa com
però preferirei essere curati in un
giardino bello che in un ospedale non so
perché io sto presentimento proprio a mi
lasciate qui bastardi l'esame mi trovo
mi fanno diventare un robot omid roio
non lo so però non ho capito cos'è
ragazzi
briga briga è chiamato ragazzi questo
era il primo episodio di the good wife
in casa troppo dire il nome non so
perché ma devi sapere comunque con un
commento se volete calo continui o no
comunque il video è piaciuto ma se
lasciato commento mi piace anche la
presa di facebook e come non invita
trovate la descrizione solo se residenti
amici diventiamo un prossimo video delle
ragazze